Congratulations. I haven't talked
to you since you got married.
Good for you.
(applause)
Funny is that you and
your wife are staying
at the hotel in Ojai close
to where I got married.
We accidentally drove smack dab
into your wedding because
my wife's involved
in something called the
Ojai Playwrights contest
a contest, conference.
And we went up there to be part of that.
We had no idea. We get there.
There's paparazzi helicopters everywhere.
I thought, I don't think that's for me.
(laughter)
It might be.
Yeah, no, not really.
(imitates paparazzi) O'Brien's headed
(imitates paparazzi) to the
playwright's conference.
(imitates paparazzi) Get him.
It was madness.
All of Ojai was complete madness
and we were right in the middle of it.
Well, yeah, and I mean, I heard that.
I, you know, I heard that
a couple of my friends were
you know, we, you know,
we had a really good time.
And then the night of the,
the, the party, they went back
to the hotel and one of my friends saw you
and he maybe had had a
little bit too much to drink
and maybe enjoying himself too much.
And apparently he was like
(drunk scream) Conan! How are you?
And you were so nice and
sweet as you are to everybody.
And he would just try and , hi
how are you so nice to meet you?
And literally his response was
BAAAALLLLLALALALLLLAAALL!
(laughter)
It's true. This guy came up to me.
He is the drunkest adult male
I've ever seen in my life.
(laughter)
And he was weaving back and forth.
(drunk screaming) CONAN!
So I started to talk to him.
Yea. So nice to see you when
you were here for recent
isn't that nice that they
got, and at one point
for no reason, he looked like
he zoned out for a little bit.
And then at one reason,
I'm not making this up.
I thought he almost
passed out for a minute.
And then he woke up and he just went,
BULLSHIT!
(laughter)
For no reason.
And then they were all throughout the town
the whole weekend. Everywhere.
with incredible hangovers.
We called her the next day.
And we say, well
the good news is you
probably won't remember
but the bad news is you don't remember
the good news is you won the wedding.
Yea, you won.
You won. You're the winner.
Yeah. You're the biggest partier.
The other crazy thing is
every single paparazzi person
in the world showed up to
get a photograph of you.
And so they wanted to get photographs
of all the people who
were at the wedding too.
So I'm walking along
(mimics unaware Conan)
and they kept saying,
Conan, how was the wedding?
How was the wedding?
And I kept saying, I'm
not going to the wedding.
I'm going to the
(nerd voice) OJAI Playwrights conference.
Typical nerd.
(nerd voice) Would you
like to come with me?
They kept asking me.
And finally, there were
these guys, I think they were
from Germany or somebody who like,
(German accent) How vas the Vedding?
And I just said, it was amazing.
It was great.
And I said, I was the ring bearer.
And I saw these guy go,
ah, he is the ring bearer.